with the consensus aiming towards an
educated public on digital privacy
it's no surprise to see an increasing
interest in encryption algorithms
we have already covered the major names
like the des and the aes algorithm
md5 algorithm was one of the first
hashing algorithms to take the global
stage
as a successor to the md4 despite the
security
vulnerabilities encountered in the
future md5 still remains a crucial part
of data infrastructure in a multitude of
environments
so hey everyone this is baba from simply
learn
welcome to this video on the md5 hash
algorithm
let us take a look at the topics we need
to cover for today's video
we take a look at what is hashing and
its principles
examples and applications we learn about
the origin of the md5 algorithm
along with its methodology we take a
look at the steps needed to create
hashed values using the md5 algorithm
and finally learn about the prospective
advantages for the same
so let us first get acquainted with the
concept of hashing
and its examples
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of information or data
beyond recognition we can achieve this
using hash functions
which are essentially algorithms that
perform mathematical operations on the
main plain text
the value generated after passing the
plain text through the hash function
is called the hash value hash digest or
in general just hash of the original
data
while this may sound similar to
encryption the major difference is
hashes are made to be irreversible
no decryption key can convert a digest
to its original value
however a few hashing algorithms have
been broken down due to the increase in
computational complexity of the new
generation computers
there are new algorithms that still
stand the test of time
and are they are being used in multiple
areas for password storage
integrity verification etc like we
discussed earlier
websites use hashing to store user
passwords
so how do they make use of these hashed
passwords when a user signs up to create
a new account
the password is then run through the
hash function and the resulting digest
is stored on our servers
so the next time a user logs into the
account the password he enters is passed
to the same hash function
if the digest matches with the one
stored in the server
then he is allowed to login to the
account this way
no plaintext passwords get stored
preventing both the owner from snooping
on user data
and protecting users privacy in the
unfortunate event of a data breach or a
hack
we also use hashing when it comes to
verifying data integrity
when a file is uploaded onto the
internet it is also passed through a
hash function
once the hash digest is generated it is
uploaded along with the file onto the
internet
when a user downloads the file for his
or her personal use
they can also get the hash downloaded
with it
once the file is run through the hash
function again
the digest is compared to the one
provided by the uploader
if the value of both the digests are the
same the data integrity is verified
and we can be sure that the data was not
corrupted while transit
to generate these hash digest from a
standard input
we use hash functions such an example of
a hash function
is the md5 algorithm let us learn more
about it in our main focus for the day
the md5 hashing algorithm is a one-way
cryptographic functions
that accepts a message of any length as
input and it returns as output a fixed
length digest value to be used for
authenticating the original messages
the digest size is always 128 bits
irrespective
of the input the md5 hash function was
originally designed for use as a secure
cryptographic hash algorithm
to authenticate digital signatures md5
has also been depreciated for users
other than as a non-cryptographic
checksum
to verify data integrity and detect
unintentional data corruption
ronald rivest founder of rsa data
security and institute professor at mit
designed md5 as an improvement to a
prior message digest algorithm
which was the md4 as already iterated
before
the process is straightforward we pass
our plain text message to the md5 hash
functions
which in turn performs certain
mathematical operations on the clear
text to scramble the data
the 128-bit digest received from this is
going to be radically different from the
plain text
the goal of any message digest function
is to produce digests that appear to be
random
to be considered cryptographically
secure the hash functions
should meet two requirements first that
it is impossible for an attacker to
generate a message
that matches a specific hash value and
second
that it is impossible for an attacker to
create two messages that produce the
same hash value
even a slight change in the plaintext
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digest
this goes a long way in preventing hash
collisions
which take place when two different
plaintexts have the same digest
to achieve this level of intricacy there
are a number of steps to be followed
before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the md5 hash
algorithm works
the first step is to make the plain text
compatible with the hash function
to do this we need to pad the bits in
the message
when we receive the input string we have
to make sure the size is 64 bit short of
a multiple of 512
when it comes to padding the bits we
must add one first
followed by zeros to round out the extra
characters
this prepares the string to have a
length of just 64 bits less than any
multiple of 512
here on out we can proceed on to the
next step where we have to pad the
length bits
initially in the first step we appended
the message in such a way
that the total length of the bits in the
message was 64 bit short
of any multiple of 512. now we add the
length bits in such a way
that the total number of bits in the
message is perfectly a multiple
of 512 that means 64-bit lens to be
precise
are added to the message our final
string to be hashed
is now a definite multiple of 512.
the next step would be to initialize the
message digest buffer
the entire hashing plain text is now
broken down into 512 bit blocks
there are four buffers or registers that
are of 32 bits each
named a b c and d
these are the four words that are going
to store the values of each of these sub
blocks
the first iteration to follow these
registers will have fixed hexadecimal
values
as shown on the screen below
once these values are initial
of these 512 blocks we can divide each
of them into 16 further sub blocks of 32
bits each
for each of these sub blocks we run four
rounds of operations
having the four buffer variables a b c
and d these rounds require the other
constant variables as well
which differ with each round of
operation the constant values are stored
in a random array of 64 elements
since each 32-bit sub-block is run 4
times
16 such sub-blocks equal 64 constant
values needed for a single block
iteration
the sub-blocks can be denoted by the
alphabet m and the constant values are
denoted by the alphabet t
coming to the actual round of operation
we see our four buffers which already
have pre-initialized values for the
first
iteration at the very beginning the
values of buffers b
c and d are passed on to a non-linear
logarithmic function
the formula behind this function changes
by the particular round being worked on
as we shall see later in this video once
the output is calculated
it is added to the raw value stored in
buffer a
the output of this addition is added to
the particular 32-bit sub-block
using which we are running the four
operations
the output of this requisite function
then needs to be added to a constant
value
derived from the constant array k since
we have
four different elements in the array
repeat
since we have 64 different elements in
the array we can use a distinct element
for each iteration of a particular block
the next step involves a circular shift
that increases the complexity of the
hash algorithm and is necessary to
create a unique digest for each
individual input
the output generated is later added to
the value stored in the buffer b
the final output is now stored in the
second buffer
of b of the output register individual
values of c
d and a are derived from the preceding
element before the iteration started
meaning the value of b gets stored in c
value of c get stored in d and the value
of d
in a now that we have a full register
ready for this sub-block
the values of abcd are moved on as input
to the next sub-block
once all 16 sub-blocks are completed the
final register value is saved
and the next 512-bit block begins at the
end of all these blocks we get a final
digest of the md5 algorithm
regarding the non-linear process
mentioned in the first step
the formula changes for each round it's
being run on
this is done to maintain the
computational complexity of the
algorithm
and to increase randomness of the
procedure the formula for each of the
four rounds uses the same parameters
that is b c and d to generate a single
output
the formulas being used are shown on the
screen right now
algorithm unlike the latest hash
algorithm families
a 32-bit digest is relatively easier to
compare when verifying the digest
they don't consume a noticeable amount
of disk storage and are comparatively
easier to remember and reiterate
passwords need not be stored in plain
text format making them
accessible for hackers and malicious
actors when using digest
the database security also gets a boost
since the size
of all the hash values will be the same
in the event of a hack or a breach the
malicious actor will only receive the
hashed values
so there is no way to regenerate the
plain text which should be the user
passwords in this case
since the functions are irreversible by
design hashing has become a compulsion
when storing user credentials on the
server nowadays
a relatively low memory footprint is
necessary when it comes to integrating
multiple services into the same
framework without a cpu overhead
the digest size is the same and the same
steps are run to get the hash value
irrespective of the size of the input
string
this helps in creating a low requirement
for computational power
and is much easier to run on older
hardware which is pretty common in
server farms around the world
we can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values
before and after transit once the hashes
match
file integrity checks are valid and we
can avoid data corruption
hash functions will always give the same
output for the similar input
irrespective of the iteration parameters
it also helps in ensuring
that the data hasn't been tampered with
on route to the receiver of the message
hope you learned something interesting
today if you have any queries regarding
the topic
feel free to ask us in the comments
section and we will get back to you as
soon as possible
subscribe to our channel for more
amazing content like this and thank you
for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here